a huge number of well-known people
disgraced themselves during the two
years of the Russian collusion hoaxed
but two of them stand above the rest
former CIA chief john brennan and former
FBI director Jim Comey we expect
lawmakers to grandstand on flimsy
pretext that's what they do for a living
we don't expect much of anything from
the news media there toady's and
buffoons but our most powerful
bureaucrats are supposed to be they need
to be impressive they have a lot of
control over this country and the people
who live here we need them to be fair
and smart and level-headed John Brennan
has shown himself to be none of those
things during his years serving Barack
Obama Brennan was known mostly for lying
under Trump he's become a full-blown
wild-eyed conspiracy nut he is feeding
and fueling hatred and animosity and
misunderstandings among Americans I use
the term that this is nothing short of
treasonous because it is a betrayal of
the nation he is giving aid and comfort
to the enemy treasonous is defined as a
betrayal of trust as well as aiding
abetting the enemy and so that was the
word that came to my mind Jim Comey
meanwhile is smarter than John Brennan
not that's hard but he's a political
partisan something that no FBI director
should ever be at times his judgment has
been bizarre watch him for example
suggest that the most lurid portions of
the obviously fake SEAL dossier might in
fact be real I honestly never thought
these words would come out of my mouth
but I don't know whether the current
President states with with prostitutes
peeing on each other in Moscow in 2013
it's possible but I don't know these
people are a joke those are the two most
powerful unelected bureaucrats in Barack
Obama's government and you would not
hire them to run a CVS they're idiots
they're self agonising narcissists who
believed an absurd story about a P tape
that ran on some cat blog and they're
not alone congressman Adam Schiff is
still rambling on like a mental patient
about crushing conspiracy from the
puppet you might think it's okay that
their only disappointment after that
meeting
that the dirt they received on Hillary
Clinton wasn't better you might think
that's okay
I think it's immoral I think it's
unethical
I think it's unpatriotic and yes I think
it's corrupt and evidence of collusion
immoral unethical unpatriotic people
didn't used to talk like that
particularly those who are already all
three but it's not just Adam Schiff the
rest of his party is already joining the
new conspiracy theory and it's this bill
Barr the Attorney General may look like
a decent guy in fact a living stereotype
of the traditional moderate Republican
but looks deceive in fact Barr is an
enemy operative a Putin stooge working
secretly for Mother Russia he cannot be
trusted or mr. Barr to quickly issue a
four-page report in his attempt to try
and exonerate President Trump as to much
of the odor of political expediency to
help the man who appointed him president
Trump so I'm Chuck Schumer says that you
can be sure the entire herd of brainless
Democratic presidential candidates say
it too I'm deeply troubled by Barr
himself one of the reasons I voted
against him I mean he should have
recused himself in my opinion so I have
a lot of problems with Barr
do you trust bars judgment on
obstruction here
no I think what the Attorney General did
is undermine the purpose of the special
council's job and I think speaker Pelosi
is quite right when she says it was not
only arrogant but very disrespectful you
know it's really hard to overstate how
dumb this is we're searching for the
words we know a lot about Bill Barr he's
been the public eye for 40 years he was
the Attorney General under George HW
Bush he gave money to jeb Bush's 2016
campaign effect it's hard to imagine
that Barr even voted for Donald Trump
not his kind of guy and yet now for some
reason bill Barr has developed such a
deep loyalty to Donald Trump
he's willing to destroy his own
reputation subvert American government
and commit crimes why in order to help
Donald Trump his new love hide his
criminal Russian collusion that's what
they're telling you it's ridiculous
insane
but they tell you a lot of things like
that with remarkable frequency that
people were supposed to be the most
impressive in our society fall for
hoaxes that no normal person would ever
believe Jesse small as transparently
bogus' hate crime a dozen more just like
it in the past two years the fake Duke
rape case they even faker UVA fraternity
rapes that Cummington high school kids
they hated American Indians weapons of
mass destruction in Iraq the fraudulent
FDA food pyramid that helped make
America fatter and less healthy eat more
breakfast cereal that'll slim me down
they bought all of this and much more
without even pausing when creepy porn
lawyer told them that Brett Kavanaugh
was a sex criminal they believed him
then they told us that creepy porn
lawyer would make a good president these
are the people who brag about how much
they Revere science or the party of
science and at the same time insist that
you can change your biological sex by
wishing it so 40 years ago these same
people warned us a new ice age was
coming now they shrink about global
warming they will literally believe
anything on the left the Enlightenment
is over
superstition reigns in its place this is
what happens when conventional religion
the ones we all mock die people who say
oh I'm secular just find something even
more implausible to believe in and
impose on the rest of us but with way
less self-awareness and therefore far
more dangerously